evie is one of our favorite villains
she's got style she's got talent and
she's so wicked we're dying to find out
where a life will take her after
graduation will mal and Evy continue to
be best friends or will life get in the
way watch until the end to find out if
Evy will have a boy or a girl
[Music]
descendants three the descendents
franchise is living proof that kids
aren't carbon copies of their parents
mal evj and Carlos might be the case but
their hearts are far from evil but then
again who said heroes couldn't be a
little wicked funny enough Prince
Phillip and Princess Aurora are good
people who have Audrey as a daughter and
let's just say that Audrey isn't turning
out as they'd expected in fact one quick
look at Audrey's new makeover is all we
need to know to realize that the girl's
a villain the d3 trailer recently
dropped and it showcased our mains in
some pretty hectic scenarios but hey did
you see their outfits they look super
cool one person who stands out in
particular is Evie but that's not really
news now is it the fairest of them all
is about to face some pretty dark rivals
and there's no way of knowing if she'll
get corrupted along the way actress
Sophia Carson who plays Evie revealed
that she's hoping her character will
develop an evil edge in the three chol
although it'd be interesting to see Evie
make her mother proud the apple fell
pretty far from the tree so we don't see
this happening unless someone casts a
spell on her let's assume that mal evj
and Carlos have beaten their enemies and
saved the world and let's jump right
into our nun preps a graduation ceremony
graduation for the longest time Evie was
convinced that she needed to find the
perfect Prince to be happy so instead of
relying on herself she put things on
pause thinking a prince would solve all
her problems so when she first locked
eyes with Chad Charming Evie thought
that she had it made turned out that
Chad wasn't as charming as he initially
let on though because sooner or later
Evie realized that he was a total jerk
Chad went behind Evie's back and tried
to get her expelled for cheating but
luckily Doug came to the rescue
Doug fell in love with Evie the first
time he saw her
he always goes out of its way to help
her realize how special she really is he
urged her to stop hiding her
intelligence which helped her shed some
of her vanity with Doug's health Evy
realizes that beauty and status aren't
the most important things in the world
so she embraces that big brain of hers
knowing this we expect Evie will be
named the valedictorian at auradon
perhaps graduation ceremony unlike
everyone else though Evie's robes will
be totally decked out her fashion game
will be on point and she'll deliver an
uplifting speech the next step
Evie grew up thinking that she was a
princess but Audrey rudely pointed out
that the Evil Queen had been stripped of
her title so by default Evie was far
from being royalty although this bummed
her out Evie still had faith that she'd
become royal by marriage but she gave up
that dream when she fell in love with
Doug nevertheless Evie is hardly ever
seen without her tiara so it's clear
that she considers herself to be a
princess despite what others might say
this is one of the many reasons why we
love Evie's personality she's kind edgy
fun and she knows who she is
so it's not surprising that she finds a
way to give her fashion designs the same
characteristics Evie is a super talented
fashion designer and makeup artist and
we can't imagine her putting these
talents on the back burner to work in an
office setting Evie is definitely going
to fashion school after graduating from
ours on prep her unique designs and dark
attributes will make her clothes stand
out amongst the other students and
before long the entire world will know
about the Evie's for hearts fashion line
this villain has a bright future ahead
of her makeover Evie and Izzy go way
back so we wouldn't put it past them to
become great friends and colleagues in
the future Disney grew up idolizing Evie
and her wicked ways so we'd love to see
what the two V caves would design if
they put their heads together when it
comes to makeover dizzy is everyone's
girl and they'll come a time when Evie
wants to up her game at this point Evie
will be around 21 years old
she'll already have a very promising
fashion career in fact she'll be
watching her designs walk up and down
the runway but every fashion designer
needs a go-to hairdresser
and assistant Evy will hire Disney and
the two will become renowned
fashionistas we're so used to seeing Evy
Rock her long blue hair that imagining
her with short hair is a hard thing to
do but we think that Evy will crave a
new hairstyle after keeping her hair
long for years
so one day she'll walk up to Disney with
a pair of scissors in her hands and say
do whatever you want
dizzy will choose a stylish bob for her
mentor and she'll die her hair a
midnight shade of blue we can only
imagine how sophisticated Evie will look
what do you guys think about this
makeover the evil spell Evie is living
her dream and so his dog however
something wicked is coming to put an end
to the couple's happiness but more on
that later Evie and Doug have been
dating for a long time now and Doug is
just about ready to propose in fact he
travelled to the Isle of the Lost
to get the evil Queens staff of approval
and well that was a huge mistake the
last thing the Evil Queen want is for
her daughter to marry dopey son so she
enchants the engagement ring with an
evil spell Doug's leaves thinking that
the Evil Queen is happy for them however
things take a turn for the worst when
Doug popped the question
the proposal is beautiful Doug takes
Evie to the place they first smashed and
gets down on one knee and that exact
moment our Don preps marching van comes
waltzing out okay well the proposal is a
bit geeky but that doesn't stop Evie
from saying yes as soon as Doug slips
the ring onto her finger Evie starts to
boil with rage
her mother's spell has latched on and
Evie turns on Doug and the students she
tells Doug that she doesn't want to
marry him and storms off the real
proposal Doug and Evie are in love so he
knows as his princess isn't acting like
herself so instead of buying a 2-liter
tub of ice cream and disappearing for a
few months Doug rounds up the troops he
invites Jay Carlos and mal to his house
and tells them about what happened
between him and Evie but the vks burst
out laughing before Doug can finish his
story mal tells Doug that he should
never have gone to the Isle of the Lost
and that by doing so he basically cursed
his relationship after some speculation
they rely
the evil queen must have been chanted
the ring and now points out that Evie
would have given the ring back to Doug
if she had truly denied the engagement
so they set off to find Evie and well
things get a little intense
in fact they soon find out that the evil
queen is about to marry Evie off to sham
use son
luckily for Doug he gets there in time
to stop the wedding and breaks the spell
with true love's kiss Evie comes to her
senses and the gang escapes back home
Evie and Doug get properly engaged and
Evie starts designing her wedding dress
a castle
Evie starts off as a shallow and
materialistic villain who wants nothing
more than to become a queen however her
personality takes a welcome to turn when
she starts attending our Adhan crap at
some things never change so we're not
surprised that Evie still wants to live
in a castle it's been her longtime dream
to live in a gorgeous castle with a
charming prince who loves her and it
looks like she's getting her wish or at
least a variation of it Doug's been
putting some money aside and with his
family's help he managed to buy an old
castle and a renovate it it's a grand
gesture and Evie's sure to love it but
that doesn't stop Doug from feeling
nervous
after all it's a renovated castle not a
brand new one luckily for him Evie isn't
the person she was raised to be so she
immediately falls in love with her new
home she doesn't care that the castle
needs some work because well she's a
castle owner for crying out loud once
again Evie is reminded that she's
marrying the nicest guy in the world and
she wouldn't trade him for all the
Prince Charming's
in the world the new fashion line
planning a wedding isn't an easy thing
to do so Evie gets her best friends to
help her out
she obviously asks mal to be her maid of
honor and she keeps busy by designing
her wedding dress
problem is Evie's got way too many ideas
and she keeps starting her gown from
scratch around to this time mal and then
also get engaged so Evie starts
designing mouthes wedding dress instead
of her own
the issue is Evie's wedding is coming up
before mouth and she still doesn't have
a gown the pressure is on and Evie's
inspiration is at an all-time high
so she jumps right into designing a
wedding inspired fashion line she names
it the ever after collection at around
this time mal and Izzy are starting to
think that Evie is never going to design
her wedding dress
since dizzy as a fashion designer
herself and mal knows a thing or two
about style they start secretly working
on Evie's dress
a few days before the wedding Evie
starts freaking out because she has
nothing to wear so you can imagine how
relieved she is when mal and Izzy unveil
their masterpiece the wedding we love a
good true love story so we'd love to
imagine just how magical Evie and Doug's
wedding would be some fans believe that
Carlos has been harboring a secret crush
on Evie which would totally cause some
tension on her wedding day however we'd
love to imagine that Carlos and Jane end
up together
and besides Doug is clearly the man for
Evie so let's pretend that Carlos is
super happy for his friend on her
wedding day but if you guys think that
Evie and Carlos should have ended up
together let us know in the comment
section Evie's dress is a breathtaking
and her crown is absolutely stunning
Mallin dizzy gave her dress the princess
feels she always dreamed up daagon
Evie's wedding is being held in their
castles garden and everyone's spirits
are high so much so that a song breaks
out which song do you think Evie and
Doug would dance to on their wedding day
if there's one thing our heroes know how
to do it's put on a show so we'd love to
see what a descendents wedding would
look like in real life and who knows
maybe it will come in descendants three
happily ever after
even villains deserve a happily ever
after and we'd like to think that
dodging Evie's relationship reaches new
heights after descendants three comes to
an end fans believe that the couple has
a baby girl in their future and we can't
help but agree can you imagine how much
fun Evie would have designing her baby
girl's outfits because we sure can Doug
goes on to study music and eventually
becomes the music teacher at our time
crab and Evie finds out that she's
pregnant about a year after the wedding
the baby girl inherits Evie's blue hair
and delicate personality and were
certain that she grows up to become the
fairest of them all so did you guys
enjoy Evie
Doug's happily ever after before you go
let us know which name you think Evie
and Doug should give their little girl
we're thinking dev give this video a big
thumbs up if you want Evie and Doug to
end up together and don't forget to
click the bell icon to get notified
whenever we post new videos thanks for
watching and see you next time on the
things
[Music]